the science guy bill nighy debated
creationist Ken Ham on msnbc.com last
night I'm pretty sure you probably know
who Bill Nye the Science Guy is but if
you don't know who Ken Ham is he runs
the Creation Museum which is a
twenty-seven million dollar museum based
on the literal belief in the creation of
the world as recounted in the Bible
before we get to the debate let's just
show you a couple images from the
Creation Museum because it is a piece of
work so what you're seeing here first is
on the left that's a Utah Raptor not a
velociraptor from Jurassic Park that's a
Utah Raptor and on the right is Cain
murdering Abel they believe that these
things happened at approximately the
same time what we have here on the left
is a painting of the Grand Canyon after
the flood the Biblical Flood the Grand
Canyon which which they claim made the
Grand Canyon literally on the right is a
as a door from the culture in crisis
exhibit because you know if gay people
have sex then we get tornadoes and
floods and things of that nature two
more for you the left
that's where Adam names the animals and
on the right is Adam and Eve in the
Garden of Eden and of course these again
these are literal things that they
believe happened in this museum played
by Demi Moore and finally on the fourth
this is Moses in the biblical authority
exhibit on the left and the right again
is the culture in crisis exhibit so you
can see if you if you walk around with
two giant tablets that tell you what the
Ten Commandments are you're not gonna be
killing people and shooting people and
things like that giant tablets in a
backpack yeah it's a lot to deal with
just a couple other quick little things
so yes they believe in this museum that
humans coexisted with Dinosaurs so
there's a chance that Jesus rode a
Velociraptor in Bethlehem they believe
that the Biblical Flood
as we said created the Grand Canyon and
that the earth is only six thousand
years old
okay we've set that up so they debated
creationism first evolution I think we
know which side Bill Nye was on
Jen I know you watched and you were
tweeting up a storm part of me was
thinking when they were doing this whole
thing and it was the number one trend on
Twitter which I was actually happy about
because it was like wow people are
paying attention to science but marty
was thinking alright or not or making
fun of it but partly I was thinking you
know we're legitimizing something we're
putting them on equal footing and that's
a problem yeah a lot of people are
complaining saying that building I
should have even debated him in the
first place because by debating him he's
acknowledging that creation doesn't even
exist and is a possibility somewhere in
the realm of science that being said
they're real things at stake here you
know he's a teacher who's teaching
creationism rather than evolution to his
students so Bill Nye obviously I think
had a personal responsibility he felt he
had a personal responsibility to take on
this debate maybe in order to save
science in order to save it from other
people that are kind of hijacking
science or discrediting science around
every corner so I get the thing about it
not being on even footing because one is
kind of I don't know completely made-up
based on you know you know and the
others made a measurable science as Bill
Nye kept going back and proving again
and again last night but I think the
debate was more culturally relevant then
maybe scientifically relevant well I
missed it but didn't I hear there wasn't
really much of a debate that there were
more talking points so him back and
forth a message in a conversation it's a
21st century debate which is not like a
real old-school debate where people
genuinely debate it's like you talk then
I toss we talk later I talk so
unfortunately we you don't get like what
the real bounce back they wanted to have
that in order I think that would be
appropriate there's lots of different
formats for a debate and this is more of
a presenting information kind of debate
rather than exactly it wasn't like they
were trying to slug it out and in the
end really crown a winner there I think
the problem with it is is that first you
know you had him go and explain for
about a half hour straight all these
things that kind of just went in circles
so basically in the beginning he was
just like what him
yeah that's right so mr. Helme went
first I need and he had was at mark I
was forget his first name him Kent came
him so County I went first and kinda
introduced himself and kind of did the
UM from Australia so you might not
understand what I'm saying thing which
is the worst
Australian yeah not even mate and and
went on to kind of you know just explain
stuff without ever really backing
science and said he questioned the
methodology instead he questioned
science overall instead he didn't really
present any sort of case for his side
rather than very small detractors from
the other side right so do you guys
think the people was in the case though
they just choose to ignore science as
opposed to come come back with something
that proves their beliefs I think it was
a lot of faulty arguments he brought on
some other people video evidence of
other scientists he knows it also
happened to be Christians right he
brought on some other you know evidence
by saying when he teaches in a classroom
he teaches children observational
science it was something that you can't
observe it was kind of like pictures or
didn't happen seriously he was like well
if you haven't observed it then it
couldn't have happened meanwhile we have
history in China and in other places
it's been written and recorded for
millions and millions of years that was
obviously observed verse one book and
this is the thing I'll just say about
the Bible if he's using the Bible as his
observational evidence that's also very
flawed because the Bible was written
supposedly by over 40 different people
over a span of 15 years the telephone
game for so many years this is what
happened and you tell somebody they tell
somebody and always changes right so do
you guys think there's any room for
these things to exist together because
it seems to me you couldn't admit that
you don't know how it all started and
you can say well maybe the Big Bang did
it but then what was before that and the
gases and all that kind of thing and
then still so you'd have some belief in
a higher powers like but then still
believe in science it seems like we
don't have any room for believing in
both in America right well I think you
know quantum physics in a way is that in
the fact that it's you know like energy
tracks like energy and everything is
energy and energy isn't doesn't
dissipate I think that that there's a
religious feel I believe to quantum
physics but it's all based in science I
mean that's kind of what I gravitate
towards yeah and also we can't explain
sometimes we'd like to explain by just
completely making things up because it
makes us feel better it makes us feel
good to feel like there's something
higher than us are more important than
us controlling it I also believe in that
sort of observational science that he
was saying you know people say I had a
feeling I just know something was there
whether it was the ghost of your
grandmother right or whether you feel
like you were just saved you know the
minute you just missed a car accident
you feel like oh wow I just know
something was watching over me I mean as
you're saying that could be related to a
quantum physics energy thing we don't
understand and I think the point in my
whole rambling thing right now is the
ability to say we don't understand but
we're gonna try to use certain methods
to try and understand it that fit within
certain guidelines so if like Bill Nye
was going look and I think he ended it
he mentioned that a few times he said
whatever we don't know I'd like to learn
I'd like to be proven wrong he's open to
that I feel like on the creationism side
like nope this is the way it had to
happen well I'm not open to poking holes
in our theory we're not open to learning
new things and that's a problem right so
isn't the real issue here is just the
leap of faith that I guess every person
either does make in their life or
doesn't make in their life you can
either say I'm gonna question this whole
thing or I just there's a lot of things
that I don't understand I'm never gonna
say and so I'm gonna make this leap of
faith and just believe in something that
can't be proven and that's that's where
there's evidence in front of you I
brought some people that's what the
basically you know bill I brought some
and especially because I from Kentucky
was even kind of almost more like an
in-your-face but he brought some
Kentucky limestone and he said look this
time stone here through the fossils in
it and do what we can show through
dating is way way older than 6,000 here
she said if the earth was only 6,000
years old as you say then there's
absolutely no way this can even exist
then he brought the physical
observational evidence right but is that
the really good evidence doesn't matter
if you if you're taking that leap of
faith then the evidence doesn't matter
you could say well I've can carbon date
this back a million years but big damn
what yeah Norah I think there's a
certain mentality of people that are
willing to look at you know base what
they think off of questions and what
they don't know versus people just want
to decide like this is what I know I
don't hear anything else I you know this
is what I believe I don't you know I
don't care what you think I don't care
what information you have in front of me
I'm just gonna believe this yes for
people sometimes I think you just be
told what to believe and not question it
and to go on that wire and it's
dangerous wild world out there yeah and
you might be afraid that you're not
gonna be taken care of by a higher power
if you start to believe in these crazy
weird scientific things which is strange
to me because believing in whatever your
version of God is entirely and placing
all your faith and that seems a lot less
like you've a lot less power and control
and self responsibility over yourself
then
believing in science so I don't really
understand that well we wake up to our
belief in Santa Claus but we don't
believe in something like that right you
know right as kids you all blow Santa
Claus that's real and you're like oh and
then it's some boy there's no way that
that's real right that's true right like
at 11 by 11 if you're not on board like
Santa's not real like you're nuts but
somehow this thing you're not nuts so
final thought on this one thing that I
did find very refreshing about it was
that we actually were talking about
science in America it was the number one
trending on Twitter as I said shouldn't
we have a science guy on TV every night
right what did that feel like
it actually like felt like it was
removing a little pain from I used to
have a science show but don't we need a
more mainstream place for it instead of
all this closest we have is like a
doctor odds or a duck based on jacked up
the type person and their role
unfortunately even though these people
are both very smart achieved men who are
physicians and understand the human body
and they're not necessarily scientists
but that's the closest we have is the
doctor with health and science is it
instead of how does it relate to you you
know it's not just science let's think
of it let's didn't want to talk about
stars and space and physics exactly we
don't really have anybody who's kind of
the mascot for science unless you're
going to like a deep cable channel you
know watching maybe Mythbusters we don't
have on a regular news a regular go-to
person we kind of like our news fast and
easy and sometimes science is not you
son easy to explain science in a 60
minute bit which is what a lot of our
entertainment is right well that's what
I meant 16 literally it's not that easy
I'm a big advocate of PBS I love PBS
have some very you know articulate shows
and information but it's you know it's
not Dallas and it's not CSI people
become interested in science we'll have
more science segments because again the
big networks are all you know they pay
attention to the advertisers so if
people say we'd like to hear more about
science will get more about science
there's no evil conspiracy to keep us
from science maybe there's certain
factions of conservatives that would
like to keep us from that but overall
it's really if we say we want science
and we start one of science programs
we'll get it on television